you know her from so many greats like er
the good wife and the sopranos
just to name a few her new book sunshine
girl and unexpected life is out right
now
please everybody welcome juliana
[Music]
margolies
i know we can't hug each other it's so
weird it's so weird
i know and i it just like doing certain
things on the show it's just still i'm
still getting used to it but
anyway what is mother's day like for you
well yes let's jump right in let's do it
we're just talking about it
mother's day well i think this year
especially um
we should all be uh just praising all
the mothers because
it is just known that most of the work
fell on mothers during covet yeah you
know and then
and in the pandemic look at everyone's
like yeah yes and i
and and i can't complain because i have
a very lovely life so
even though i was having moments of
complaining because of the laundry and
the cooking and the shopping
all of it isn't validating all of that
stuff there's so many incredible women
out there who are single mothers
who lost their jobs like i just feel
like this year that
we should all just celebrate every
mother
and that we've made it yeah yeah
but my favorite you know i'm not a big
um
i mean of course it's always nice to get
a little present but really for me all i
want is a card for my kid
me too and coffee in bed oh i
well my kids are far too young to do
that yes so i started teaching my son
how to make coffee for me around seven
oh my daughter's about to be seven here
we go yeah don't start now okay
okay then you know if you're a little
anal attentive like i am you might not
you might not want them to bring you the
coffee until they're a little older
oh because they spill it unless it has a
lid unless it has a lid but to me
sitting in bed with a cup of coffee on
mother's day with my husband my kid my
dog
that's my idea of a perfect mother's day
yes i get it just relaxing and not
having to move
and not having to move or wash a dish
amen um
so well your son kiernan he is he about
to be 13 or he is 13. karen just turned
13 and
j just january 2013 teenager
i have to say i have a five-year-old boy
that just turned five so what do i have
to look forward to with teenagers
oh you know well he's still at a great
stage i don't know any further than 13.
okay one thing i'll say is um
i know i'm most mom i i don't know why
boys are so smelly
the smell starts happening in the feet
the b.o it's shocking um
in our house we were like hearing your
rank i am sensitive to smells
yeah well when they when their hormones
are going those smells come up
really fast so that's something you can
look forward to um the other thing
though is
conversation you know yeah when they're
this age i mean
really from the age of 10 on but at 13
he's learning so much and dinner
conversation just becomes a different
a different experience a little elevated
it's elevated and we have topics of
conversation and especially during covid
when we were together every night which
is rare for most families to have both
parents home for dinner and you know
yeah we would pick we would all say what
did you learn new about your day
you know that was his idea and i was
like i love it okay this is what i
learned you know
and just there's a an ease of
conversation and communication
um that i find really refreshing but he
hasn't hit the
i hate you stage yet so when that
happens i'll come back
but you know i i love that your kid i we
thought of that up um
my ex and i like when we were together
we thought up at the dinner table like
saying
one positive thing and one thing that's
not negative but you'd like to change
it is like pulling teeth like it's like
with my four-year-old he's like i'm like
what did you like about today and he's
like i don't know
i don't know he's already a teenager i
don't know i'm like okay cool
yes that's boys too you'll say how was
school good
what'd you do stuff yeah i don't know
don't expand girls are like
oh well let me you know there's so much
more communication she goes into details
well we actually started out we got in a
fight but now we're good and we're best
friends again it's like a whole thing
anyway they are different it's another
rad mom hour again give it up
and for juliana y'all so their mamas are
here all show
um long in honor of mother's day uh so
we've got stephanie over there who i've
known for
a very long time ma'am because jason's
been with me since idol so
she is the mom of my band leader jason
hi stephanie
hi kelly thanks for having us i i love
you i love you coming on here so wait
you two look so much alike though i've
always thought this
well actually we do you're right kelly i
said
but i always say i'm the one with hair
by the way
[Laughter]
so wait did did jason tell you not to
say anything that might
embarrass him because i want to know
that thing
okay well he did text me and he reminded
me it was the kenny clarkson show
and not the jason halbert show
[Laughter]
well he thinks he's got the worst
singing voice
in the world he does not i yes i agree
i totally agree with you i totally
disagree with him
i'm always asking him why don't you sing
more his voice is unique
i tell him it's like rod stewart and i
do believe i've told everybody in the
band that jason needs to sing more
so jason please sing for your mama
so okay what i got from this is that we
need to do a duet jason on the show
okay yeah yes that's what i heard
season 10. that's what i heard that's
what i heard
that's coming for you mama i love this
right now his face is so red stephanie
we can accomplish mission accomplished
all right all right
well juliana so is your son do you
embarrass him if you ever
um he says i don't embarrass him
i will threaten to embarrass him all the
time um
keep him in line just to keep in mind
the only thing that embarrasses him is
when
um when he was like three we got a video
of him running around the yard
with his son hat on totally naked
chasing after um
his grandparents dog and with just
everything hanging out and i have it and
i always say just
know that i will play that video
for sure at some point like either your
graduation graduation or your wedding or
something but i actually said to him the
other day i was like
um would it embarrass you if i don't
what i was doing something in the
in the we were walking in the street in
new york and he goes mom
no you're in a mask like right now
nothing embarrasses him nobody knows the
only thing that upsets him is if
anyone's ever rude to people
he gets very upset that's great yeah and
calls them all karen's
she's like oh my god that woman spoke to
that taxi driver she's such a karen
oh my god and i didn't know what karen
was until he
taught me two years ago i was like what
what's a karen
i didn't know oh my gosh i know he'll
let
he's like you better never be a karen i
was like i'm not then you will embarrass
that many times
and i would embarrass him um well your
new book it's called sunshine girl so
why sunshine girl
so sunshine um girl was a nickname my
mother gave me
um when i was pretty much right out of
the womb
because i didn't cry i was very
i was just very peaceful and smiley and
she used to say she'd come into the into
my room at nine in the morning because i
never woke her up
well you know and i'd be standing there
wet from head to toe just smiling so
she called me her sunshine girl and i i
ruminated a lot on that
title but it made sense to me because
throughout the book i talk about
how it's a real disservice to label your
children
because it was a nickname that was out
of love
but it was crippling for me because i
couldn't be anything else
because i thought that's what was
expected of me right so with all the
difficult stuff that happened i was the
one who
felt like i had to cheer everyone up and
make everyone feel better because your
sunshine girl
and be like oh no we're moving where and
we're living i'm good you know like
never having that
and i brought it into my adult life
where i didn't know how to set
boundaries to say no that actually that
i didn't want to be difficult because i
was the sunshine girl we are so
similar yeah yeah i was like wow i'm in
therapy
yeah i was like no that's so it's so
true that you're no i feel like that too
i was always the kid to be like uh
yeah like i just want to make everyone i
don't want to make anybody uncomfortable
i don't want to that's a lot of a lot of
kids growing up in those environments
yeah and and to the other
effect too you know if you say oh that
that's my melancholy kid
oh she was always so melancholy they'll
grow into that if that's what you put
that on them you project that on them
yeah so i feel like it's one of the
reasons why i loved michelle obama's
book title called becoming because she
talks in her book about
let your children become don't ask them
what they want to be when they grow up
when they're seven
let them become that person they're
gonna be and the same with nicknames as
much as you think it's cute
you know it it stays with you in
different ways and it comes
out i was really it was quite cathartic
to write this book because
i i got to dive in pretty deep and and i
realized i was like wow
i didn't really start drawing boundaries
until i was 35.
oh my god i'm 38 and just now figuring
that out so
i feel better yeah i'm like i'm just
saying
it's very it's very hard it's hard when
you have a life of habitual
like patterns that you yeah especially
if they're like embedded from childhood
because
and you think you're you think you're
you're trying and you're doing your best
and you think you're being compassionate
and you think you're doing all these
things and really you're doing the
opposite
right yeah listen no one wants to hang
out with a martyr
yeah yeah yeah it's not it's not really
no one wants to be on either it's
exhausting
so juliana's new book a sunshine girl
and unexpected life is out right now you
gotta check it out
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure